yeah
[Music]
I'm actually a bit more nervous the last
time I don't know why but so maybe
because we're close to releasing a new
version and I just being bothered by
work but today I want to talk about
something you know it has something to
do with you as you'd expect but it's not
a sales pitch it's really about my
interesting discovery that we are seeing
a new trend of defining UI components
somewhat differently from what we've
been used to
and so let's dive in how many of you
remember a code like this backbones the
good old framework that introduced the
custom the MVC into front-end
engineering and this is how we define a
view in backbone it's not necessarily
the equivalent of a component as we see
today but you see the similarity and you
can instantly understand what it's
trying to do and in case you've noticed
views current API actually takes them to
some node from this as well
we have viewed on extent but then we
have something called yes classes ever
since class arrived it seemed just
obvious that we should just use classes
to define components now all right and
in fact a lot of these major firm which
today do that react digit create class
to use class angular obviously use
classes Ember aralia a lot of these
early priorities that used to use these
this object to find format for defining
components move to classes once it
became an actual part of the spec but
his class really the best way to define
components well it seems pretty good
because classes allows us to define
state and defying methods that would
manipulate that state this is what every
UI component tries to do and we use the
instance of the compar of the class as
the render context so in order to expose
the state and these methods
to our templates or render functions
which were whichever you prefer
but in for a period of time we've we
felt like what well this seems like the
obvious right way to do things but then
we discover we actually need to do more
with UI components than just dealing
with State and functions that change the
state we also have to deal with props or
inputs data that's passed into the
component from the outside world because
we are actually using UI components we
were composing them in a view hierarchy
and there will be data flowing from top
to top down so we need a mechanism to
receive outside input and you might find
this familiar here so just a disclaimer
this is not the API of an actual
existing framework it's intentionally
generic so that it doesn't look like any
one of them but you might be find some
of them familiar and then we also need
to handle side effects and life cycles
components are UI components can be
mounted on mounted hidden shell moved
around so there will be a lifecycle for
these components and we need sometimes
just need to hook into it to perform
side effects that that's not a direct
result of rendering something onto the
screen for example logging to the
console is a side effect fetching some
data and then do something is a side
effect right we need to hook into these
life cycles and then sometimes we need
to also perform side effects reacting to
state changes could it could be a change
of a prop or it could be a change in the
components own state but as you can see
we are starting to introducing more and
more new concept into a simple class and
a lot of these are not necessarily bound
to the class syntax like we are using a
decorator here we're using a special
named hook hoping that the framework is
somehow know when to call it and these
are all hidden contracts conventions
extra concepts that you need to know in
order to alter a component using classes
so it's not simply a class anymore right
and even more we have to sometimes
attach metadata to the component that
simply no there's no way to elegance
we've described in a class
sometimes maybe you can use a stack
plant static class field to to declare
these extra metadata but realize that
class fields are still at stage 3 after
all these years and decorators still ask
stage 2 we've been using it for such a
long time and very few people actually
realize it decorators is far far away
from actually being part of the language
and so on and on so many so many
overhauls that it's very different from
what we kind of knew when it was first
introduced another problem with classes
is that logic we use in composition can
be challenging at times not impossible
but challenge to get right right this is
one of the reasons why in the
traditional LP designs design circle you
you hear the phrase all the time favored
composition over inheritance you need to
apply these patterns these patterns
these patterns just so that you can get
it right and and another important
problem is in front-end UI components
inheritance isn't really that useful how
many you have actually had a direct
class extends which follows is not
actually just a base component right
it's really rare
the reason is UI component rarely works
like this a linear hierarchy of
inheritance where the child class
strictly extends the base class and just
ask something on top of it this is we
know this isn't inflexible because you
are encapsulating fixed behavior inside
the base class and when you have
multiple child classes each with
different behavior it more often looks
like this right we're trying to have
several different types of components
some of them with overlapping behavior
so it seems more make more sense if
we're just trying to compose things
right but composition in classes is also
challenge to get right you it may come
to mind that you can we can use mix-ins
but mix-ins has its fair share of
problems namespace clash and and when
you use a lot of mixed things you don't
really know which mixing injected which
property which is one of the reasons why
we add kinda Claire mix things are dead
and you should use higher-order
components and then
render profs and then now we are trying
to come up something new and angular
trying to deal with this with service
classes and then you need to go into the
rapid halt of understanding how
hierarchical dependency injection works
finding out the right place to inject
your services and and even services
service classes has a limitation of not
being able to directly hook into your
component api's because when you use a
class the component API exposed using
these specially named hooks on your
class methods and inside a service class
which is isolated from your component
class it's not directly available so the
coupling is also a problem well this all
of these is not saying that classes of
batch voice wow people have been
building great UI using class base to
component api's but maybe just maybe
components is not the most natural fit
for describing UI components or maybe
it's not the only way of describing UI
components so one thing I want to
mention here is we're talking about
classes we're also talking about where
this what I call semi class-based API is
like views to point X object based API
backbone views all of these kind of
center around the idea that your
component has an instance called this
and you somehow attach all your state
onto this and somehow you change
everything through this right but what
if we get rid of the concept of this so
the past year we saw some interesting
new ideas appearing and some of you
might have seen this tweet from me I
think a couple months ago what a buncha
likes but I don't I don't know how many
people actually read these little
comments it's hard to see here so we'll
dig into them we add hooks how many of
you have used react looks a lot of you
great so rare hooks was introduced last
year and the syntax looks like this the
interesting part is react looks is not
actually defining the state on a spot
it's actually storing the stage you're
using in an array on the underlying
instance of your component instance and
these functions are called on
every single update and they are just
retrieving the online states based on
the call call order index so the first
call of use state will retrieve the
first the state at the first slot on
component it's an interesting design so
so this is a short sort of a sampling of
a few things you can do with classes you
can declare state you can define the
moist derived state sort of like a
computed property you can you can
perform side effects in lifecycle hooks
so here use effect when you pass it an
empty array it's like calling something
unmounted or you can react to changes
performed side effects based on only a
part of the state that you care about by
passing in this dependency array like
the +1 or you can change the state by
calling set count which is a function
specifically for that state that can be
obtained we also have few composition
API so this is something that we've been
having RFC olanta discussions in the
view community about and went through
some iterations we have a plugin that
allows you to try it out with view two
and this is going to be ship that's
built in view three view composition API
is really not introducing any new
concept in terms of view but more about
exposing views internal API is like
allows you to explicitly create an
object that is reactive and then allows
you to create a computer property based
on that reactive State allows you to
[Music]
watch a function and automatically rerun
it whenever the state relies on changes
allows you to inject lifecycle
side-effects allows you to mutate the
state right doing the exact same thing
as last slide and you can see the
similarity in here right the difference
major difference here is view
composition API isn't repeatedly caught
on every render this is called only once
at your component startup and then you
return an object containing the things
you want to expose as the render context
so behavior wise it actually
this actually leads to some very
interesting behavioral differences
compared to react classes and then we
also have spelt which is a very novel
and interesting approach spell 3 allows
you to write your a component code like
this this snippet is doing exactly the
same thing as the previous two examples
but you can see it much more concise
interestingly and it doesn't it looks a
little bit different from the typical
JavaScript that we know because when you
try to change state it's directly
mutating a loco variable which
supposedly should have no side-effects
it should not trigger anything but
somehow spelt makes it work but again it
looks quite similar similar so just to
go back a little bit and you can see
through approach is very different
online implementation but the
conceptually they share a lot of in
common a departure away from classes so
disclaimer I am the author of you so I'm
likely biased towards the composition
API maybe you'll hate it but here I'm
just really trying to focus on the
trade-offs that went into these designs
so let's go into them the common theme
we're moving away from a declarative bag
of options object or a bag of methods
define on a class to a more somewhat
more freeform way of defining components
notice I'm not using the term imperative
or procedural here because we're still
writing components we're still
declaratively rendering stuff we're
still composing a review using
components it's not we're going back to
imperative programming to code UI it's
just we are using a more free informed
format for authoring and defining our
component logic the pros the biggest
obvious Pro of react cooks is enable
some really really smooth and easy logic
composition right so customer hooks
prefixed with use prefix allows you to
encapsulate arbitrary logic you can just
really take any part of your component
logic out into an external function and
then you can share it across
ponents so you can encapsulate a global
theme sharing logic inject that is dark
property so these are all hypothetical
use cases but notice how you can pass
the result returned from one hook into
another so this is kind of cross module
composition and then in a hook like use
Mouse position the hook may contain
side-effects like setting up a global
event listener and also contain the code
that cleans up that listener nicely
hidden away and then you can compose
arbitrary number of these different
function modules very clearly inside
your component because it's very clear
which property is coming from which
customer hook you're using so here's a
screenshot that when hooks were
introduced people start to realize how
much nicer it feels when you transition
from classes to hooks
notice how features pertaining to
different code pertaining to different
features colored in different background
colors when they move to hooks they come
they can be naturally grouped together
and the code becomes shorter - another
big Pro of hooks is hooks design is
actually directly sort of a side effect
result of the the incoming concurrent
mode so react can come on concurrent
mode allows you to slice work up
scheduled them make sure your apps stay
responsive but it also sort of leads to
some limitations because we add has to
design an API that forces you somehow
forces you to write code that is
concurrent mode friendly and hooks is
one of the pieces of that grand scheme
so here I'm going to talk about some
cons of the hooks design so don't worry
I'll talk about the cons of other all
solutions - including views so first
thing is you have to manually manage the
dependency array of use effect or use
memo you have to remember to passing the
correct things so that they in the inner
callback invalidates correctly and you
have to rely on a linker to get right
because it's close to impossible for you
to always room
passing the correct things and that
indirectly leads to the stale closures
problem so if you've used Oaks you
likely know what I'm talking about when
when you pass them when you pass a
function into use effects that function
may get reused across subsequent renders
and if your dependency array is not
invalidating that inner car back
correctly then your inner car back
captures the variables of a stale
closure
so in this case it might be a little bit
surprising especially when you first
start to use hooks that the inner count
will always log zero because it's always
capturing that count variable from the
first render so the correct way of doing
this is you have to passing the count in
the array and then properly reset
teardown and reset up the set interval
every time count changes so now let's
talk about view composition API
interestingly if you composition API has
the almost exact same composition
capabilities as you can see this is the
exact same snippet from the react cooks
example and you can pretty much do the
same thing in view composition API
there's really not much in terms of
composition capabilities it's almost the
same and we also have real-world cases
where when we refactor a big old options
API based component into composition API
we see how the code becomes much more
coherent for each feature nicely grouped
together well another difference is
because we're caught only once so view
has this concept of automatic dependency
tracking when you try to react to state
changes when you try to compute
something and memo is it you don't have
to think about when something changes or
when something validates because view
automatically tracks everything you've
touched inside the execution of your
code so that you don't need to think
about it well here comes the cons we
need the concept of because we're not
invoked on every rendered somehow we
need to be able to pass
a reference to primitive values around
so that we can track its reactive
changes so this ref concept is basically
an object that wraps an inner primitive
value so that we can somehow pass it
around without losing its reactive
connection to the original so now we
have two concepts we have the concept of
ref and the concept of a plane reactive
object which is something you kind of
have to juggle around from time to time
but just so you know when dealing with
the steel closure problems and cooks
react also has a ref concept which is
different from States so trade-offs
trade-offs and then there is the run
time dependency collection overhead
right it's relatively fast and efficient
but when you have a huge amount ADA it
can still be a noticeable overhead so
that's just the intrinsic trade-off
we're making well then let's talk about
the pro of stout is it obviously offers
the most concise code the way spell does
it is a little bit interesting because
it's all compiler based imagine you are
writing a babble plugging that
translates the view example well we
can't actually write a babble plugging
that reverse convert spell syntax into
the view syntax and we can also write a
babble plug-in that convert the view
syntax into the smell syntax but I'm
lying the way you spell does it is when
you inside increment function when you
mutate the count spelled injects another
line of code underneath it's a
invalidate count so and inside your
component
whenever you in your template if you use
count then inside up the the views
update functions about will add a line
saying check if count has changed if has
changed update this part of the Dom
smart right and very efficient very very
little runtime overhead and also it's
automatically tracking the dependencies
so you don't have to worry about
yourself well there are also some
interesting limitations to this because
this syntax is very tightly bound to the
current component context so when you
lift it outside of the component it just
doesn't make sense anymore
right it's it doesn't make sense without
a component context so when you're
trying to share a logic across small
components you will suddenly have to do
without this magical syntax and you have
to drop down to a different completely
different set of API is called spells
store which looks quite similar to views
composition API in some way but well
here's the thing is when you have a
component component written because
spells syntax relies on this magical
conversion you can't really just like
freely take it out of your component
share it with another one or extracting
into reusable utilities you kind of have
to rewrite it with a different syntax to
be able to reuse it
another thing is some of the custom is
syntax felt is using confuses third
party tooling like typescript
types I really don't understand where
this +1 comes from it's interesting
because syntax weisfelt is still valid
JavaScript this dollar sign Colin is
actually a label in the Java it's a
valid JavaScript syntax but when you try
to give the label a different semantics
than what job it means in JavaScript you
are inventing something kind of behaves
differently from JavaScript and that
confuses third-party tooling and
sometimes you would also create little
weird cases where for example when you
have an array and you mutate its inner
values you have to assign the array to
itself to let's well know that the array
has been mutated so as you can see three
approaches similarities different
trade-offs different design decisions
it's hard to say which one is best even
like as biased as I am I don't think any
one of them sort of is clear it has a
definitive advantage of the others but
another thing to note is this common
departure from class is not about
functional program versus opie because
as you can see even when using classes
you're not necessarily building your UI
with opie principles and
when you're using not using classes like
in these examples they're not really
that functional programming esque so
just want to make it clear this is not
about FP versus all P at all I prefer to
think about these approaches as think of
UI components as instable stateful
modules right imagine how you write your
typical JavaScript today you start with
an es module it's proceed it's sort of
procedural code inside the module but
then you can freely group your logic
into functions you can extract those
functions into another module you
compose them together importing
functions calling functions here inside
functions inside functions right so it
kind of gives us give us an ability to
sort of think about constructing UI our
component you our logic more natural
like we're just writing normal
JavaScript instead of sort of trying to
fill in boxes filling in these blanks
left to us by a framework in the
presented to you in the form of a class
right so um are these definitely better
than classes are one of these better
than the other I honestly don't know
they're all pretty new right
most of them are all around only around
for one year or so and I think there are
plenty of room for improvements and
future iterations and over I'm just
really excited to see these new ideas
coming up and I'm excited to be on this
journey with you guys and try to find
better ways of building web applications
thank you
[Music]